- [Instructor] In other
videos, we have touched on
the idea of property
rights, but in this video,
we're going to go a little bit deeper,
and think about how
property rights connect
to the notion of a market.
So, first of all, think about
what a market means to you.
You have probably heard of
things like the stock market
or you have probably gone to a supermarket
to do your groceries.
What's common about these things?
Well, if we wanna say
as broad of a definition
of a market, you could
view it as a market forms,
let me write this down.
Well, this is an informal definition.
Forms, when multiple parties,
multiple parties,
exchange things of value.
Exchange
things
of
value.
And let's see whether our
notions of a market hold up
or whether this definition
holds up when we think
about our notions of a market.
Well in a stock market, you
have a bunch of people together,
and they are trading stocks,
and usually what happens is,
let's see if this is a
stock right over here,
these are all different
shares of the same stock
or different stocks,
what typically happens
is if there might be parties
who want to sell this stock
and then there's other parties
who want to buy this stock
and then whoever of the
buyers is willing to offer
the most for that share,
well then that money
will go to the seller of the
stock and then that stock
will go to the party that
just paid that amount.
And so you see that there's an
exchange of things of value.
At a supermarket, you will see
aisles and aisles of goods.
This is my drawing of a aisle of goods,
and there's all sorts
of merchandise on 'em
and you put 'em in your shopping cart
and then when you're done,
you go to the checkout,
this is my little shopping cart here.
You go to the checkout
and you pay for them.
So once again, you are
picking which items you want.
There's a price on them, so
the seller which in this case
is the supermarket, tells you
what they're willing to take
for those items and then when
you put them in your cart
and then take it to the
checkout, that's you agreeing
to pay those prices and so
you exchange, once again,
money for those things of value.
So the money has value
and those groceries,
whatever you're buying, might have value.
Now, we tend to believe that
markets are the best way
of allocating resources
and different markets
work different ways.
As you could just see,
the stock market could be
very different than a supermarket
and then you could have an auction
where things are auctioned off.
That would also be a form of a market
but the actual mechanics
of how things happen
would be a little bit different.
But a key factor that you
need in order for markets
to function properly is
that you need to have
a notion of property rights,
and as we've talked about
in previous videos,
property rights are the idea
that things can be owned.
Now what does it mean to own something?
We almost just take this for granted
but it's not some law of the universe,
it's something that we
just assume culturally
and it's become so embedded
in us that we just say
of course you can own something
but at the end of the day,
there's three real properties
to owning something.
One is the idea
of a party being able to
exclusively own something.
So let's say that you own a piece of land
that you want to farm on.
Well that means that
you can exclude others
from using that land and
whatever that land produces.
It might just be a fun
place for you to run around
or sunbathe or it might be a
place where you grow some food
that you have the rights to
the benefits of that thing.
Now another key dimension
of property rights
is that those rights
have to be enforceable.
Enforceable.
What does that mean?
Well, if someone obnoxious wants to come
and sunbathe on your property
that you have enjoyed
running around and
sunbathing on, you say hey,
you're infringing on my property rights
and you should be able to call the police
or some type of enforcers
to take that person
off your land if you really
do have property rights
and if they are truly exclusive.
Or let's say you have
property rights on your shoes
and if someone were to steal your shoes,
you should be able to
call the police and say
a crime has been committed and the police
should enforce those property rights.
They should go and get those shoes back
and punish that shoe stealer in some way
and then last but not
least, in order for markets
to work well, those property rights
have to be transferrable.
Remember, a market is
all about transferring
property rights.
In the stock market, one party is giving,
is transferring their
property rights to that money
to the seller of the stock
in exchange for getting
the seller of the stocks property rights
to the actual stocks.
If this was not transferrable,
then it would actually make
no sense to have a market as we know it.
So I'll leave you there.
These are things in our daily life
that most of us take for granted
because we live in a market economy
and we are used to things like ownership
but there are definitely
ways of organizing society
where it's not as based
on markets in terms
of who gets what and even
today, markets in many sectors
or in many parts of the
world don't operate as well
as they could because
some of these dimensions
of property rights aren't
working as properly
as they should.
It might be hard to
transfer property rights
in certain markets.
In certain markets, if someone, let's say,
just takes over a property,
the government might not be so good
at enforcing those property rights.
Or it might be hard to keep one party
from using something of value that is,
at least according to the property rights,
owned by someone else.